cuz I feel like a lot of people
categorize me as like oh you're all
right but like I trained for 1 month
never really done anything ever you know
well if you do do it again just get 50%
up front yeah dude get that 25k in that
bag dude yeah I'm going do get 150% up
front and then you give them back the
[Laughter]
[Music]
50 welcome back to a followup of a
careful Boys episode where today in the
seat and in the house we have just
Michael over
here we was just finishing the
conversation in the last OTR about your
fight that you had a celebrity fight
between Tik tokers and YouTubers and you
went against FaZe Jarvis is that right
yeah yeah so so tell us how that fight
went yeah so okay so long story short uh
Austin McBroom came to my house like 3
months before the fight about just
randomly like ding dong and you're like
who's that on your ring camera like
that's exactly how it went and then and
then he pulled through and at the time
this was when like I remember too this
was like obviously when I was like up
there so he came with like a bag of like
25 G's but it didn't I was like a tight
move huh I was like I was like okay this
is this is kind of like in like a Whole
Foods bag or what kind of it's just in
the backpack I was like I was like cool
okay that's how he rolls did he give it
to you no he didn't give it to me oh no
what he just showed you yeah I thought
it was like check this out put it back
on that should be in advance if he's ask
if he's asking you to fight for him he's
like fight on my promotion here's 25k I
only remember actually I'm not going to
lie to be honest though 25k is not that
much in like bands yeah yeah not if it's
all $1 bills
Jo two and a half stacks I had 3 months
to basically train for the fight and uh
two out of those months the first two
months I didn't have any trainer cuz I
was trying to find someone to to help
train me but they didn't give us any
trainers and all that stuff and the
person that was training like the
ticktockers I I just didn't feel like it
was it was right for me like it just
didn't feel the right was out in Florida
no no oh wait what say during this time
were you out in Florida no this was in
LA was it seven Goose boxing gym was
that who was training all the remember
but there's 7,000 boxing coaches out
here though yeah there's a lot I I I
didn't find the right one and then by
the last month I found someone that I
really enjoyed so that that last month I
trained every day but yeah did that one
month and then everything happened and
then it was pretty much downhill from
there damn would you do it again yeah I
would dude you should do it under him
but you'll do it again if you get paid
I'll do it if I get paid and if I feel
confident like they didn't pay you they
didn't pay so you mention you mentioned
that $400,000 is on the line right how
did that come up in
conversation uh you guys didn't sign
nothing like like my no we signed
something the thing like awesome room he
super snaky he [__] put it under like
his his uh company thing where it's like
oh like we don't we didn't make enough
money of this and that and we had a
clause in my contract where it was like
no matter how the event does I should
get paid but he finessed it to where so
if he bankrupts it it's like he can't
exactly it's like oh I don't have money
if I'm B yeah exactly so is C you signed
up this guy comes up with a $225,000
advance doesn't give it to you then you
sign up for this fight says $400,000
online whether you win or lose and you
have closet says regardless of fact you
get paid M you go in there you get
knocked down one time the ref [__]
calls it and you don't get paid yeah
damn that's [__] did anyone else get
paid only Bryce because he had a
contract specific I guess with him
directly opposed to the company oh that
was his event are you in Austin still
friends no way huh they're best friends
I me showed up at your house I was like
he must be no no he just showed up for
the one time so wasn't it was it what
was it like five Tik tokers five
YouTubers I think it was like five or
six yeah so that out of like [__] 10
plus people no one got paid one person
got paid yeah so Al wait that's the one
with Alex right no Wasabi no we were the
one before that I think the first one oh
was Graham Stefan on your car no cuz I
know Graham Stefan was in 2 wait Graham
Stefan did did a boxing match I would
say we were the event that started all
of them oh okay okay okay who did Austin
McBroom fight that night Bryce Hall oh
God that was that was that was the one
where he the meme was like oh I'm not a
fighter I've never claimed to be a
fighter but like the whole promo was
like I've fought so many fights like
that whole thing y haven't seen he's the
C A Different yeah yeah and he's the guy
who organized it and didn't pay nobody
yep well cuz I really like fighting so
when I saw like cards where it looks
like no offense to you but when I saw
cards when like everyone else just looks
like a clown it doesn't really attract
me unless the story Line's good like
like Jake Paul kind of like made me
become a fan of his fights in the
beginning I was he's just another clown
too but he's so good at marketing that
you get sucked into the narrative that
now I'm like I actually want to see him
fight and I want to see how he does I
mean they make a lot of money now
because especially because of the yeah
people like when they look at fights
they don't care about the fights they
care about like the person I guess
that's more important the story the
drama when I heard about like um I I
doubt it's going on now but like the
Elon versus musk like them possibly
doing a boxing fight versus musk is good
he's fighting yeah zuer yeah that would
have been good and they were talking
about doing it at the
Coliseum that's [__]
hilarious so crazy real I think they
couldn't agree up uh on the streaming
terms cuz one wanted to do it on uh
Twitter the other wanted to do it on
Facebook and yo but the funny thing is
like how Zuck was like like calling out
musk for ducking all the time that was
pretty funny I don't know yeah I I mean
he yeah Elon doesn't train so I was just
like you see over here Zuckerberg he's
like winning like doing actual things
he's about it yeah yeah I was like a
there's no way if everyone's like oh
he's going to have the neuralink and
he's going to
[__] oh yeah so what what what weight
did you fight the Jarvis at I was
one
135 holy [__] 138 something around there
it's pretty damn light and that's all in
the contract like you got to make I how
many gloves was it 12 or 14 I think it
was 12 I I could be wrong though we
didn't have headgear though what was
your first sparring session like how did
that feel yeah especially if you never
fought before I I I only the I only
fought my trainer but he just keep it
was like it was like a beat down yeah
yeah yeah I had like a couple like oh
okay hold on and then got two cocki when
you got knocked down did you tell your
trainer see you [__] suck dude no
when I got knocked down I was just
pissed I was like more frustrated cuz
like I knew the consensus of like social
media already like I was already the
underdog so like I was and you know
that's going to be instant meme now yeah
100% because it was like oh this guy
from fortnite oh 200 whatever whatever
the [__] the the fortnite terms are so I
already felt that and then when the
contact came out and all that stuff okay
so long story short first round happened
the end of the first round my contact
came out cuz I got I got clipped and
I was like -4.75 so that means like I
can't see anything clear after like here
so like one was clear one was here so it
was just very like I was like super you
can't do a timeout somebody put a
contact no I I tried they were like nope
nope you can't you didn't practice like
grabbing fishes out of water like blind
fighting yeah cuz like when Van Dam got
pepper in his eyes he he kept fighting
bro are you too young for a blood SPO I
would have I would have but they did the
stoppage and I was I was he's too young
for blood sport if he watched Blood
Sport he would have fought blind make
sure you get your coach gets you a koi
Pon to fill it up with KO your coach
should have took a bandan put it around
your eyes and sent you out he should
have done the kickboxing rout too
[__] dip your gloves and [__] glue
and then diamonds and [__] diamonds I
don't want to keep the diamonds no
yeah at least you get paid that time
know where were you when you found out
that you weren't getting paid and how
did that feel it was like a few months
after it was like a long delay like oh
we'll get it handle we'll get handled we
not going to get handled [__] you never
went like [__] better have my money no
I tried but like couldn't do anything
about it did you talk to other Fighters
too did you get paid and then they're
like yeah no one got paid we're like no
we didn't get paid what makes you want
to do it again if you didn't get paid
like what's the draw for the second one
I I really enjoy like feeling like I can
kind of like do anything I put my mind
to on some like cliche but like
realistic like I really like I I've
never wanted to be in like a
and I felt like that was an opportunity
for me to just try something out cuz I I
feel like I'm a hard worker so it feels
like an adventure like a big challenge I
mean it's like it was something I've
never I I was never going to be able to
experience that you know like other than
that kind of like situation so if I did
it again like I would want to have like
that Underdog Story again where it's
like all right I did this but it was
like for one month this is how I
actually am you know cuz I feel like a
lot of people categorize me as like oh
you're all right but like I trained for
one month never really done anything
ever you know well if you do do it again
just get 50 % up front yeah dude get
that 25k in that bag dude yeah I'm going
do get 150% up front and then you give
them back the
50 I got to start doing that sounds way
better no right now I feel like my focus
is on the dance world like I really want
to try to see how I can like make a make
a make a splash in the Dance World make
my money there and then when I'm
chilling like that could be like a side
quest yeah for sure is your main source
of income through Tik Tok and
sponsorships yeah for now right now so
when you say like make money through the
dance world what do you mean by that
like how do I I hear this a lot from
dancers is like it's hard to make money
as a dancer so I'm just like figuring
out like and and if you're not doing I
guess shows or like uh like like you
know the the what is that the [__] um
the the not the kjas but
the Yeah Yeah with their own show like a
booking commercial
like their own show or like or like
music videos or like whatever the tip of
his tongue dude he was trying to get it
out you got to say another group to
think I'm in a social media fight every
day
here also not you're well respected here
Anthony come on um so for the dance
world I I I do feel like they're
undervalued so like I'm trying to make a
change where like one I feel like I'm
I'm like in this good opportunity where
like I'm in the dance world but I'm also
in the social media world and there's
not a lot of people that do both and I
kind of like one I want to make like my
own thing so I'm trying to I don't even
know what I should say until it's
official but like I'm talking with
steezy right now okay I might be you
know doing some type of partnership with
them and then for my social medias for
like my dance Channel I want to kind of
be like the Mr Beast of dance so think
of like squid games sh well dance but
dance Edition you know like how dancers
go up against each other type of thing
oh okay would basically put those
together I have connections with labels
I'm already talking to so I would start
my own campaign SL content with like
just new stuff that people haven't seen
cuz Dan hasn't especially on on social
media it hasn't been like updated like
it's all kind of the same stuff like
dance classes dance
tutorials dance concerts like everyone
kind of has a rinse and repeat model
yeah there there's no new content
there's no like elevated stuff which is
really weird to me you know because like
dance it it it's literally like the
front face in thing of like
entertainment so like if I were to have
this Powerhouse of like this Empire
behind me maybe I could like start a
union one day and like make sure like
people are paid correctly cuz I feel
like dancers they get paid like paycheck
to paycheck and it doesn't even cover
rent for like a month in La you learn
all this [__] during screen printing
yeah I mean cuz I I was like I was
getting paid like a hundred bucks for a
music video in Miami you know so I was
just like this is not realistic cuz
there's no Union for dancers yeah
dancers Alliance you know what I mean
but that wasn't really established till
much later and I also feel like that
only works in one sector of like the
dance like yeah commercial work but like
the whole world doesn't revolve around
like the LA scene as well yeah like 90%
of my [__] income doesn't even come
from La you know so it it doesn't apply
yeah I just also feel like the whole
like thing about dancing is like people
they're used to like they this is like
what they were given so they don't like
try to push the boundaries for it so
like if they have to do Patricks they're
going to they're going to accept the job
for whatever pay they are or like get
treated the way they are I just heard so
many bad stories about it and want I
hear like pay rates for like being on
like really big shows it's just like
it's really weird yeah I think Dan focus
on their not saying this is a bad thing
but they focus on their Artistry more
than the business aspect and their
Artistry is the business so like trying
to find a a bridge that you know is able
to bridge that gap between those two is
hard to do especially if everybody's
we're sensitive you know yeah but that's
like that with every um industry like
actors cuz even like like like a
personal trainers the could be the exact
same one at a 24-hour
fitness knows the same amount as the guy
with 5 million subscribers and this
guy's making like 20 bucks an hour and
this guy's making a couple Mill like him
yeah it's and they know the same it's
just one knew how to like transform
what's in his brain into a
business that's crazy yeah but right now
I feel like there's no one on the like
the the Pinnacle of dance like there
used to be like should I say his name
yeah just say it so there was this guy
that's he's he's off the grid now
because of like sexual allegation like
really bad [__] with his stuff putting
out there what's his name um uh Willer
Beast you know I'm a beast the company
it was like the biggest Dance Company in
the world know well it got crashed down
like crazy tons of people came out to
talk about it all of that stuff and I
feel like right now there's no one there
there's no one that's taking over like
the dance social media is all kind of
like everyone's freefor all or like yeah
and I'm like oh I can I can do that let
me let me kind of so there's no like big
Kingpin of dance that's what I feel at
least you you may think that from the
outside perspective but from the inside
perspective it wasn't all that for like
them being on the top of like the dance
Pinnacle or like well I guess I'm
meaning more in the social media aspect
cuz as a business it could have thrived
like they had the views they had the
numbers and all that stuff I know I know
the business side very well I worked on
it but I I I did hear it was like very
flawed I don't know it was extremely
flawed yeah talk about it what are the
flaws [__] where do I start you talk
about the flaws you talk about the
sexuality dividing might be the same
thing there's a little bit of cross over
there oh that affects business huh way
well we'll have to have a private
conversation I mean what I'm what I'm
hearing from you is it sounds like
regardless of their success or whatever
but their perception was they were the
elite and they have um they have pool
cuz they have an audience and they're
doing it on social media and they could
have maximized that potential right 100%
yeah so like they could have been broke
as hell but you're saying like they they
if they did it the right way they did it
the right way they could have done it
really well I see yeah so I feel like I
think Dancers just suck with business so
that's why you
know I'm just kidding I don't know
that's why uh Anthony face you got to do
it right I think I think um dancers do
bring in so many views though it's crazy
but I think like like how you said about
longevity I think if you don't make a
connection through words or like
communication I think it's hard to
follow someone um with physical movement
and establish a more deeper connection
um and I think that's why usually like
some if it's music or something related
like if you're a pop star plus you dance
well or like dance is like an accessory
to a musician or something and I or
you're a group with like um like some
kind of like what do you call it like a
story and brand behind it and then
people could be like yeah like I buy
with K just cuz like you know like I
like how they are what they represent
but then if you're individual and you're
not speaking to the public I think
that's that's really difficult to build
a long-term fandom yeah I agree I agree
that's why I'm trying to make dance long
form that's the biggest thing cuz like
if I talk about the story of like how
that's why like with ABDC right with all
these shows like you watched their
Journey that's why you fell in love with
these people instead of just the product
you see the Journey of it and that's
what I'm trying to do with like YouTube
and stuff now too but yeah it's it's
definitely it is always going to be like
uphill battle though like no matter how
like much you put like dance forward
it's always still going to be like 50%
of the product that you create because
the other 50% is going to be the music
so unless you're also the music producer
or Creator and stuff like that you're
going to be limited like that's why
social media has always been like a Crux
for us because you can monetize off of
things you can build the same type of
structures or or fight the same
algorithms you might be able to use some
to your advantage and like ride off of
the cailes of like a song's Fame but at
the same time you're still paying more
to the song than you're getting paid for
it you know what I'm saying so it's like
that's just kind of how the ENT like you
could have a video that has a million
views but then you technically made zero
on it because it was a copyright yeah we
have like so many videos online that
have millions of views that we don't get
paid for because it's it's copyright
music you know what I mean so it's just
that's just how it is but if you have a
brand and you have connections to labels
you can like kind of make a deal with
them cuz I feel like some of them are
coming around now with social Med you do
got to be pretty [__] big and and and
a lot of it is right place at the right
time too because theyve Al it's a
relationship right those record labels
also have to acknowledge and be willing
you know at that time but when we were
coming up doing dance videos they were
all like no like you
us and suddenly like you know when new
social meds come and then the virality
hits in a different way suddenly it's
like okay maybe we should flip the
script on this but then we're already
like 5 years out the game you know what
I'm saying so it's just a a just that's
just the way the world works though you
know yeah so they wanted us to shut down
JK when we got on um In Living
Color back then they didn't see YouTube
as support like social media was not
support for big channels that's crazy
for them it was like Oh no you're
competition we don't want you guys doing
skits and any of that stuff uh and then
we got on the show but you know we
didn't even actually continue cuz we
said YouTube is going to go further than
TV and then they shot like a bunch of
episodes it didn't even air so we made
the right move yeah but In Living Color
is a great it's a big brand it's like
Matt TV you know it's like it could have
gone somewhere but I
think you know the people that maybe
made those decisions at the time they
didn't have the future in mind and then
imagine now if like they they brought a
sketch comedy show and they brought all
the best sketch like from you know reals
to everything like YouTube and they
brought everybody together might do
really well yeah [__] dancing I right I
don't think so I don't think so dude you
know who the king of dance is Michael
[Music]
Jackson